[Musica]
dimostra di essere un uomo quante volte
ce l'hanno detto sin da piccoli non
essere una femminuccia si uomo e con
questa idea di dimostrare di essere
uomini passiamo tutta la vita a sfidarci
tra uomini a litigare per un parcheggio
a non accettare uno sgarbo a non
accettare che sia possibile che una
donna ci dica di no che una donna c
contraddica che una donna ci lasci anche
usando la violenza per difendere il
nostro onore di uomini il nostro la
nostra immagine
la chiamano mascolinità tossica tossica
non solo perché appunto produce violenza
contro gli altri contro le donne ma
anche perché produce una miseria nella
vita degli uomini perché in gabbia gli
uomini in
una necessità di mantenere sempre la
faccia di stare dentro un ruolo molto
rigido e soprattutto di pensare che la
nostra identità dipenda dal nostro
potere dalla nostra capacità di
controllo di noi stessi dell'altro e del
mondo attorno a noi
insomma una vita sempre sotto l'ansia
della prestazione e del controllo ma se
invece provassimo a cercare il coraggio
di rompere questa gabbia di rompere
l'idea di dover essere un monumento di
se stessi di dover corrispondere al
proprio onore alla propria immagine
pubblica insomma l'idea anche di sfidare
un po l'imbarazzo la difficoltà il
ridicolo
quando a tre anni ci si dice non
piangere se non sei una femminuccia
se ci pensate ci stanno dando due
messaggi le femmine sono ridicole perché
sono emotive instabili ma gli uomini non
hanno diritto ad esprimere a riconoscere
ad essere in contatto con le proprie
emozioni quindi una gerarchia che
produce anche una miseria
invece forse l'imbarazzo è importante
perché l'imbarazzo è quell esperienza
quella sensazione che ci dice che stiamo
toccando i confini della identità che la
società ci autorizza a percepire è
appreso quando ci sentiamo in imbarazzo
sappiamo che stiamo per fare qualcosa a
cui non siamo autorizzati io per esempio
sono come tanti degli uomini forse anche
qui presenti sono sempre stato un ciocco
di legno a ballare perché mi vergognavo
a ballare oggi non so ballare lo stesso
però accetto l'imbarazzo che vivo nel
mettere in movimento il mio corpo che
invece aveva sempre tenuto sotto
controllo ecco provare a lavorare su
questa esperienza in cui il coraggio non
è la sfida contro l'altro ma il coraggio
e la sfida contro quella regola
invisibile che mi dice sempre di salvare
la faccia e un modo per rompere uno
stereotipo lo stereotipo della donna
debole ed emotiva e del uomo tutto d'un
pezzo però ecco quando si parla di
stereotipi cominciano subito qualcuno
comincia a sbuffare dicendo ecco adesso
ci verrete a fare la predica io vado
molto nelle scuole i ragazzi dicono ecco
adesso verrete cdc di rete
questo si può dire questo non si può
dire questo si può fare
insomma la dittatura del politicamente
corretto
quello che è giusto dire quello che è
rispettoso dire
e su questo la reazione è io sono
trasgressivo non sto a queste regole
io me ne infischio di queste regole in
realtà se ci pensate cosa c'è di
trasgressivo in quella battuta sessista
in quella battuta omofoba nella
barzelletta un po misogino nella battuta
sulla propria collega d'ufficio in
realtà non c'è lui nessuna trasgressione
sono comportamenti molto conformisti
molto vecchi che potremmo aver visto già
50 anni fa e che si riproducono sempre
uguali a se stessi ecco una delle
trappole del discorso pubblico oggi è
proprio una forma di conformismo che si
maschera di da trasgressione che ci dice
che i ruoli tradizionali e naturali di
donne e uomini sempre uguali a se stessi
nel tempo sono la naturalità e la
spontaneità in realtà è perfettamente il
contrario quando noi li mettiamo in
discussione
cerchiamo di svelare di rendere visibili
quelle regole invisibili che
imprigionano i nostri comportamenti che
appunto ci dicono questo si può fare e
questo non si può fare se fai questa
cosa non sei un uomo se fai questa cosa
non sei una donna e attenzione non solo
questo produce un conformismo c'è
qualcosa di più questi comportamenti
falsamente
trasgressivi in realtà impongono delle
regole le impongono a me quando in una
classe noi prendiamo in giro ragazzino
dicendogli sei una [ __ ] se è un
finocchio non stiamo semplicemente
insultando quel ragazzino non lo stiamo
isolando non stiamo stigmatizzando chi
ha un orientamento sessuale diverso
dalla norma stiamo avvisando tutti i
maschi presenti in questa sala che se
non si comporteranno rispetto a quello
che il mondo si aspetta se usciranno dal
recinto della viabilità tradizionale
precipiteranno nel ridicolo nelle
femmina toe appunto in quell'immagine
che va stigmatizzata e marginalizzata
allora il tema è che quella
comportamento apparentemente
trasgressivo la parolaccia volgare
in realtà è un dispositivo che impone
una regola molto rigida così come a una
ragazza quando le diciamo che comporti
come una poco di buono ti vesti come una
poco di buono in realtà le stiamo
dicendo una cosa precisa devi essere
carina e piacere agli uomini ma la tua
libertà sessuale non è la stessa che ho
io come maschio maschio posso vantarmi
di aver avuto un sacco di donne tu se lo
farai sarei considerata appunto una poco
di buono e quindi il tema è riconoscere
come
esistono modelli naturalizzati cioè resi
naturali per quanto sono introiettati da
noi e capire come su questo si produce
continuamente una pressione su di noi
anche su di me maschio bianco
eterosessuale che continuamente sono
sotto la minaccia di una perdita
d'identità se non starò dentro i canoni
che mi sono stati imposti socialmente e
non a caso oggi da cambiare tutto viene
raccontato per gli uomini come una
minaccia
gli uomini sono femminilizzati ormai
anche la moda non ci si capisce più
niente gli uomini hanno perso la loro
virilità ancor di più gli uomini hanno
perso non solo la virilità perché
effemminati si truccano si vestono da
donne ma gli uomini hanno perso anche
quella virtù virile dell'autocontrollo
anche la violenza contro le donne viene
raccontata con l'idea che gli uomini
sono confusi che non hanno più quella
legge dei padri che gli insegnava a
rispettare le donne insomma un po una
nostalgia di quando i mulini erano
bianchi gli uomini arrow virilmente
capaci di dominarci e le donne stavano
al loro posto ecco questa idea la
raccontava un po mia zia ma oggi poi
viene vestita in modo molto più elegante
da illustri psicanalisti che dicono
l'uomo è la norma
la donna el emozione senza la norma
paterna la nostra società perde le
proprie regole e cade nel disordine ecco
questo è uno degli elementi che dice il
cambiamento è una minaccia ma c'è un
ragionamento più generale che dice il
cambiamento è una minaccia per gli
uomini perché gli uomini sono
discriminati pensate a chi contesta le
pari opportunità dicendo ma perché
devono passare avanti le donne e non gli
uomini che se lo meritano oppure gli
uomini sono discriminati nelle
separazioni familiari
gli uomini sono oggetto di un
pregiudizio ce l'avete sempre con gli
uomini di te che gli uomini sono
violenti
c'è come un ribaltamento dei ruoli per
cui io da una posizione di potere mi
racconto come vittima e spesso gli
uomini violenti si raccontano come
vittime come vittime di una situazione
che ha fatto come dire entrare in crisi
la loro idea di se stessi perché si sono
sentiti minacciati
ecco qui c'è un elemento in più che
secondo me non va liquidato c'è una vera
sofferenza maschile c'è un vero disagio
maschile nella nostra società ed è il
disagio che deriva dal fatto che quei
ruoli tradizionali
l'essere l'uomo che porta i soldi a casa
l'uomo che sul lavoro costruisce la
propria identità si sono infranti essere
l'uomo rispettato dalla propria compagna
che lo assiste e che lo rispetta ecco la
verità è che dietro questo c'è una
storia che ci dice che se gli uomini
continueranno a vivere il cambiamento
inseguendo quel mito tradizionale io
basto a me stesso io sono padroni di me
stesso io mi sono costruito da solo e
poi magari arriva una pandemia che ti
dice che non serve a niente
invulnerabile che non siete niente
autosufficiente oppure arriva la crisi
economica e ti dice che non è vero che
tu basse a te stesso e che sei padrone
del tuo futuro ma devi fare i conti con
la tua vulnerabilità ecco allora
quel mito virile dell'uomo padrone di sé
artefici del proprio futuro che
controlla la propria compagna se stesso
le emozioni che un mito che produce un
vicolo cieco perché condanna gli uomini
a inseguire un impossibile
rappresentazione di se stessi e questo
produce anche una violenza perché
produce la violenza frustrata che vi ha
neanche strumentalizzata nella nostra
società oggi uomini che si sentono privi
di potere privi di ruolo privi di
identità hanno qualcuno che gli dice
ecco la colpa è delle femministe la
colpa è delle pari opportunità alla
colpa è degli stranieri la colpa di
qualcun altro perché devi dare un senso
alla perdita proprio di senso della tua
vita perché quell idea iniziale non
funziona più e allora non basta chiedere
agli uomini di essere buoni responsabili
rispettosi delle donne di essere
democratici di fare spazio il tema è
provare a spostare il modello non più
cavalieri salvatori di donne che stanno
ad aspettare addormentate che qualcuno
vada a salvarle ma uomini che vivono in
un mondo in cui le donne mettono in
gioco il loro desiderio la loro libertà
la loro autonomia e uomini che scoprono
che questa cosa arricchisce la loro vita
non le impoverisce però noi non abbiamo
ancora le parole per raccontare tutto
questo oggi un uomo che si prende cura
dei figli viene chiamato mamma
cioè un uomo che fa le veci di una madre
un uomo femminilizzato david beckham
bian è preso in giro sui social perché
si prende cura dei figli allora il tema
è se non abbiamo le parole per nominare
il cambiamento per riconoscerlo per
dargli una visibilità sociale quel
cambiamento non riesce ad avere spazio
non riesce a realizzarsi non esiste se
tu non riesci a nominarlo
e così la retorica dei padri che si
prendono cura dei figli diventa solo
ironia sui padri che si prendono cura
dei figli ecco io penso che invece noi
dovremmo provare anche qui a darla in
positivo gli uomini possono restare
uomini e nel santo essere capace di
prendersi cura dei propri figli essere
capaci di intimità e di relazione di
cura
allora la domanda che ci dobbiamo
chiedere domandare come uomini e ma
vorremmo tornare indietro vorremmo
tornare al ruolo di nostro nonno avere
una donna muta e disponibile e avere dei
figli
rispettosi che ci temono oppure invece
ci piace di più una vita in cui come
uomini possiamo essere dei padri
accudenti presenti in relazione con i
nostri figli e magari vi è una un mondo
in cui incontriamo il desiderio il
piacere l'autonomia la libertà delle
donne e scoprire che questo arricchisce
le nostre vite non le impoverisce perché
non viviamo in un mondo autistico con
donne e mute a nostra disposizione ma
donne che ci rimandano invece il loro
desiderio ecco io sono un maschio bianco
eterosessuale normodotato sano
produttivo il mondo in genere mi chiede
di farmi carico delle responsabilità del
mio ruolo e io penso che questo sia
importante che gli uomini riconoscano il
loro privilegio il loro potere ma nello
stesso tempo non basta riconoscere i
diritti e la dignità di chi è fuori da
questa norma il tema per me è
riconoscere come questo mio potere
questo mio privilegio abbia anche
costruito una gabbia mia vita e allora
quello che voglio fare non è un percorso
in cui
rinuncio semplicemente a un potere per
una scelta volontaristica ma perché
penso che mettere in discussione quel
potere è l'unica occasione che ho per
costruire la mia libertà
grazie
[Musica]